Hello!
It is time for Drew's News,
your ice cold, good news slushy
without that painful brain freeze.
(Ross laughs)
Oh, yeah.
And with me at the desk is my little slush puppy,
Rossy Ross Mathews!
Yes! Hi, hi!
Hi, everybody.
(audience cheering)
(Ross laughs)
Well, first step in the headlines,
we really gravitated towards this,
because the "Friends" Ross and Rachel debate
that will never die-
Mmm hmm.
What does it exactly mean when you're on a break?
Hmm.
Well, according to Bustle,
it means whatever you want it to.
But, both partners gotta be on the same page.
A break doesn't necessarily mean a breakup.
Therapists say that you have to do this right.
Both people have to want whatever they choose, 100%.
And you gotta set crystal clear parameters.
Are we dating other people?
Are we canoodling?
First, second, third base,
the whole enchilada?
Aruga.
(Ross and audience laugh)
And finally,
you gotta set a concrete date for coming back together
and hashing out what needs to change.
Ross.
What?
Thoughts?
No, 'cause I don't like this at all.
(audience laughs)
New flash,
if you're on a break, you're single.
Because,
the whole point of being in a relationship
is learning from each other,
working through things.
If you are gonna tap out
(hands slap)
when times get tough
(hands clunk)
you're not ready for a relationship, bottom line.
Bottom line.
(audience clapping)
I never liked on a break.
On a break?
You don't take a break.
I just move on.
If you're taking a break, just move on.
That's not gonna work out.
Sorry, Uncle Ross just broke the news to you.
Sorry.
(Ross chuckles)
Hey.
Yeah?
Ross of a different kind.
What do you mean?
Of the Ross and Rachel.
Never mind, moving on.
Understood. Okay.
(audience laughs)
Hey, moving on.
We've got a whole,
a new kind of steak in food news.
This is weird.
Num, num, num, num.
(Ross and audience laugh)
Okay, Food & Wine reports the internet debut of,
get this, you guys, the dishwasher steak.
That is a steak that is prepared in your dishwasher.
(audience groans)
Yeah, I know,
but it's taking the internet by storm.
Take a look at this.
No soap, no dishes, just a steak.
One hour, 45 minutes.
(child chatters)
And we're going.
(dishwasher door shuts)
Oh, my God.
And we have a sous vide steak.
(audience chatters)
Why? Why, why?
When there are so many other options,
right there in the kitchen,
that get hot, can cook a steak?
(audience laughs lightly)
This is what makes me realize
that when we all thought we were like,
laymen in the kitchen cooking our Lean Cuisine,
that we were just sous viding the whole time?
(Ross laughs)
So sous viding is what?
You put it in plastic and it sort of sucks it,
like, it's a Vacu Seal.
It's usually a Vacu Seal and then it's like,
cooked in hot water, right?
Or is it steamed?
It's steamed, some-
Hot water, right.
Again, Lean Cuisine.
Hello people, we've been fancy all along.
(audience laughs)
Well, okay.
Here, we have one.
(audience chatters)
These were cooked in our dishwasher.
That's hot.
Also, they are seared afterwards.
So apparently,
the hot water sous vide process tenderizes
and gets this perfect cook on it,
which I have to say up front,
I feel a little guilty.
One steak, an hour and 45 minutes of hot water?
Not the most efficient, like, way to cook.
Okay, that's true.
So, you have a real beef with this?
(Drew cracks up)
(audience laughs)
I do, Rossy, I do.
(audience clapping)
But, then you sear it and I gotta say,
this looks pretty good.
Uh oh.
(audience laughing)
I know.
Okay.
I don't wanna like this.
I don't wanna like it either, but it's so good.
(audience laughs)
It's about the texture, too,
which is that whole sous vide thing in the dishwasher.
What?
(audience giggles)
Man.
I'm never gonna do this, but I am going to eat this.
Yeah. And it's not carbs.
And it's not,
for the first time here at the desk,
she's not force feeding me carbs.
Actual protein.
Thank you, Drew.
I know, I'm sorry.
I'm always force feeding you carbs.
Why is it so good?
I'm like a little bird that comes in your nest
(audience laughs)
and is constantly like,
shoving carbs down your throat.
I got croissants today.
I know.
(audience laughs)
Yeah.
I do.
(upbeat music)